入場カード dimension ボックスっていうなんかなんかこんな記念すべき
遊戯王カード発売日だったんですけどめちゃくちゃねえんだめっちゃさあちょっとの
友情カードを舞台にね
もうほぼ徹夜で友達と海に行ったんですけど8店舗外観忙しそうだと見て8店舗くらい
いたんですけど
6店舗即売り切れ一切なし即売り切れて買えなくて何度も観3000部位神3点
ああっもうを記録のおかしい静岡時の美的は魚があって本一日中授業花が咲かせたんで
気付いたらこんな時間になっちゃって今日は
って亀頭にやりますで適当ではないんですけど適当じゃないんですけどそっちは時間が
ないのでまぁタイトルにある通り質問を募集させていただきます
いや申し訳ないですけどここで見栄を張っても仕方からもう正直に
今日は授業カードを買い入って一日が終わってしまいました
悔いはありませんってで質問コーナーの猛暑でございますホント皆様の良い
良くも悪くもよ良い質問のおかげでなんとかしそうコーナーとても皆さん楽しく観て
いただいているようでうれしいんですけどもなかなか時間がかかるので今回はちょっと
余裕
上方から今回は多分時間がかかると思うので余裕を持たせて告知させていただきます
そうだなぁ
に youtube のコメントでをかけたので今日は今日はて今回を twitter
で募集しますショットで今回の質問コーナーは twitter 数の募集になります
a
ニューヨーカーして今日は g 1月26日もクリスマスのでカーじゃねえかああ募集
期間は同データ狂この日から12月の11日論日曜日の兄13時59分までとさせて
いただきまーすどうーどぅクリスマス
食べめがけていくと思いますよはい続けて今回の質問のクリスマスが使い良い質問
ホラーですね結構余裕を持って12月11以上なんですけども
このポイントじゃないですねこんなコメント楽なんですけど今回の質問コーナーは
twitter でツイートしてください
@ hazime 札を付けなくてって言っを北に質問したいけどもう質問コーナー
じゃないねもう質問コーナーじゃない
もう質問方ですねで
リクエストコーナーがわかりやすいね質問コーナーと言いますけどまぁリピートしたい
こと知ってもコーナーみたい言葉搭載ことはこれだけはお前に言っておきたい暴言誹謗
中傷はやめましょう
皆にも何でももう何でもいいホンダてもいい点がも適当にあゆエイドいいよもう何でも
いいすっとかでも前ためだ
そんな辞めたければやめてほしいそれだけはやめてくれ誹謗中傷以外のよろしく頼むよ
ってほんとなんでもいいので思ったことを twitter で
つぶやいてくださいね何が僕に言いたいことをっパンって書いた後にしたに発信た気を
付けて下さいハッシュタグおいこら肇社長にしましょう
いいともう汗たが多い頃はじめシャツを待遇に付けてツイートしたら僕がね検索して
食味つきやすくなるのでぜひそちらを乗せて国に質問を出してください
猪毛ダーツ回だけをちょっとね寝ずに優良カードタイに行くの本当にしんどかった無事
をやってる皆さん変えましたか僕の割でも買えない人が続出してますよ
ちょっと共有仰天買っていただい
行ったら明日東京じゃ場所は東京だねって言うけどちょっとねパパたまたしますので
今日はね質問コーナーポストでございますぜひ皆からさんでも聞きたいこと是非是非
書いて下さいじゃあ質問コーナーぜひクリスマス近くにぼ会いしましょう
スピーカー今日セカンド車本物だったじゃん
[音楽]